My name is Mary Weatherford,
I graduated from Princeton University
in 1984 with a degree in visual arts
and art history.
I loved museums from the time I was
a little girl, but my father would pick me
up like this and just hold me in front of
a painting for as long as he thought it
would take to soak in.
I remember very, very clearly in front
of "Crows Over a Wheat Field,"
so I was sort of helpless, I couldn't turn
anywhere, and he held me there and he
said to me, "This is the most frightening
painting I've seen in my life."
And I had to kind of take that in like
"Why would a painting of birds over
a wheat field be frightening?"
I sewed every piece of clothing that
I wore from the time I was twelve years
old until I graduated from high school.
I designed it, I thought it up, I sewed it
so I was just like a walking fashion show
like every day I had done a lot of work
in the theater in high school.
So I went to Princeton on a theater
scholarship. I joined eXpressions dance
troupe, so I was in eXpressions, and
on team theater.
What happened was I thought, well,
"I don't know what I'm here for, but
it's time to get serious and to get some
kind of a serious career, right?"
I was in the architecture department in
the beginning and I thought, "Oh, okay,
this is what I'm going to do."
Which is sort of some kind of cross
between thinking and making art.
I enrolled in Jerry Buchanan's beginning
painting class. He was so great.
Jerry taught me about careful looking.
Then the next painting class I took was
with Heidi Gluck.
Heidi taught me about color.
You know, when I left Princeton, I knew
I wanted to be an artist. I moved to
New York and I started working for
galleries and I always lived in a tiny
apartment. I had my first exhibition
in 1989, a solo project room show at
P.S.1. which is very unusual.
I was twenty-six years old.
I sold everything in that show, and then
took the money and rented a studio and
then worked for another year and then had
my first gallery show and sold everything
in a week. I was very popular for about
two years. When I paint, I paint by myself
and no one can be here. So I come down
here and I make some coffee and I sweep
the floor and I procrastinate and I read
the paper and I start mixing colors.
Right now I have pieces of neon in the
work. On the days that we're doing neon,
I have a full house. I have like three
guys here and Maurice here and it's really
fun. We have music and lunch.
It's a great time.
I wanted to make urban paintings.
I wanted to make paintings about people's
lives. And then, when I stumbled upon
using the light, then that became clear
to me. It was a way of making paintings
about some kind of representation of
the complex symphony of human experience.
This is my presentation for Frieze London
2015, which is an art fair. I will be
showing ten paintings. They're very much
about outside experience. This one I made
on the Fourth of July. There were a lot of
neighborhood fireworks going off. I went
down to San Diego, I was on a steep beach
and the wave would come in and then hit
the beach and then make another wave
coming back while this first, and then
another wave would come and then the
waves would come and hit each other like
this. Like you could you see through the
wave bodies falling through the wave.
It was an incredible experience. My work
has over the years looked very
different, one piece from the other. And I
always thought that this will make sense
when you look back over twenty years.
It makes sense looking back on it now.